all right ted thanks for that other news  here at five the southern nevada health  district is launching a brand new  program  and it is to fight drug overdose it is  called  linkage to action or l2a and it's  actually a  mobile outreach unit so the unit which  is funded by the cdc  is going to partner with different  community providers and they're going to  help connect people who are struggling  with drug use  to services like treatment or housing it  comes right to them  now the unit will be able to travel and  prioritize locations where the resources  are needed most so  places like homeless camps or even some  of the tunnels where the homeless live  for more information on the program you  can head to our website at 8newsnow.com